Ukraine's Air Force says it's shot down
18 of 24 Russian drones launched at Kiev
so this comes day after an alleged drone
attack on the Kremlin Russia had vowed
retaliation for what it called an
assassination attempt on President
Vladimir Putin by Ukraine President
Vladimir zielinski denied the charge
saying Ukraine fights on its own
territory
so Russian State media have reported a
drone attack caused the fire at another
oil refinery in southern Russia it
happened near the black seaport of Novo
roses in the early hours of Thursday
more than 150 firefighters were deployed
to the area they extinguished The Blaze
after about two hours an oil storage
facility in that same region caught fire
on Wednesday for more on what's
Happening and Russia will bring in
journalists Julia chapavo lava she's
joining us from Moscow so talk to us
about what happened yesterday in terms
of the attack on the the reported attack
on the Kremlin what was the official
reaction
yes sure of course as you said the
pressure is mounting here in Russia the
official narrative is that that in the
early hours of May the third two
Ukrainian uavs approached the Kremlin
which obviously serves as the official
residence of the Russian president uh
they were intercept intercepted by
Russian security personnel and both of
those uavs were downed with their debris
capturing on the kremlin's premises
according to the Kremlin spokesman uh
President Vladimir Putin was not present
at the Kremlin during that attack and no
one was hurt as well as no material
damage was caused by the incident so
Russian officials immediately blamed
Ukraine for the attack and called it a
planned Act of Terror and an
assassination attempt on President
Vladimir Putin saying that Russia has
the right to respond to the attack on
the Kremlin where and when it sees it is
appropriate we've heard from the head of
Russia's lower hazard of parliament at
the state Duma as saying that his
deputies will demand the use of weapons
that can stop and destroy the key of
terrorist regime and also Dmitry
Medvedev who served as Russia's
president in 2008 2012 wrote that
President zielinski should be physically
eliminated but probably the most
important thing according to the
officials is that the attack won't
affect the Victory Day Parade on May the
9th in the capital it will take place no
matter what and President Putin will
take part in the celebrations so what is
the reaction of sort of wider Russian
Society to all this
um of course we've also gauged some
other opinions of some other experts
they say that it's commonly known that
as a rule President Putin don't often
works from the Kremlin especially at
night so basically they do rule out the
assassination attempt they presume that
that attack could have been carried out
by some pro-ukrainian activists saying
that it was rather a demonstration of
certain possibilities and capabilities
so it was more of a symbolic attack as
the drones obviously were shot down over
the Senate Dome of the Kremlin over
which the Russian flag flies uh or it
could have even been an inside job from
the Russian side with possible goals to
justify intense strikes on the of the
Russian troops at the decision centers
in Kiev or to cancel the parade on May
the 9th on Red Square all right thank
you Julia for that update from Moscow